[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
this is the epitaph of seikelos
an ancient greek song dating to the
first century a.d
it's one of the oldest surviving pieces
of music
it contains advice on living in the
present moment with a limited time that
we have on earth
i've been exploring how early human
cultures understood time and how the
first civilizations created methods of
communicating this phenomenon
a phenomenon that even today we know
frighteningly little about
from misplaced fears about the mayan
calendar to why north korea is currently
stuck in year 111 if you've ever
wondered where our version of time comes
from you're in the right place
as we explore
the myth of time
for most of human history there has been
one very basic way of telling the time
the day
judging on where that floating orb of
warmth is or isn't you have a rough idea
of what time it is but aside from a
steady cycle of seasons there's not much
to go on
there is some evidence of the first time
keepers from our distant past
this is the ashango bone it was
discovered by a team of archaeologists
in the congo central africa on closer
inspection they noticed that the bone
was covered in tiny notches
these markings didn't seem to be placed
at random they were arranged into three
columns and were sorted into what looked
like a tally chart what's more two of
the columns added up to the same number
sixty at twenty thousand years old many
believe that the ashango bone is the
oldest calendar in human history perhaps
it was used to record different phases
of the moon or to track a menstrual
cycle or pregnancy but then again others
say that they're reading into it a bit
too much it could also be a bone with a
bunch of scratches and nothing more
either way it's left to us to speculate
if it is a rudimentary calendar it's one
of the earliest attempts at recording
the flow of time
some of the first recognizable calendars
come from mesopotamia roughly 4 000
years ago when these people looked up at
the night sky they saw more than just
twinkling lights they saw data
they recorded the moon's phases a cycle
of waxing and waning over 30 days they
noted that at various seasons the moon
was in different places in the sky
tracking its movements they devised the
world's first lunar calendar a 12-month
year synced up to the orbit and rotation
of the moon with the system of time in
place they knew when to farm and when to
perform rituals to the gods like inanna
the goddess of love and warfare you can
see her in the night sky most mornings
shining brightest as she descends below
the horizon you'll probably know her
better as the planet venus the morning
star
the ancient mesopotamians were some of
the first to join groups of stars into
constellations giving them names like
the bull of heaven
the goat fish
and the great twins
today we call these taurus capricorn and
gemini
they are part of a larger group of star
signs that the greeks called little
animals
or zodiac
whilst these early calendars were built
around the moon
other cultures experimented with its
counterpart the sun the emerging
civilization of ancient egypt has always
been blessed with the nile's regular
annual flooding they called it the
aquette where the river rhythmically
exceeds its banks replenishing the soil
with nutrients the egyptians noticed
that whenever this happened the star
sirius was in the same place in the sky
just above the sun at dawn they figured
out that if you counted the days until
this pattern repeated itself it would
arrive at the number 365.
they created a solar calendar consisting
of 365 days
with annual events sinked to the seasons
they worshipped the sun as a god ra
as he strode across the sky on his sun
barge they built obelisks in his name
like the great monument of heliopolis
the city of the sun the work of these
egyptian stargazers would be confirmed
thousands of years later when
astronomers learned that the planet
earth indeed takes 365 days to orbit the
sun
although technically it's 365.25
days we tend to ignore that 0.25 but
that's a quarter of the day six hours
in four years you're a day out of sync
if you wait 120 years you're a month out
of sync to account for this discrepancy
the egyptians added an extra month every
now and then to make up for lost time in
our calendar today we include a leap
year an extra day every fourth year
these early lunar and solar calendars
are only two examples across the world
cultures were able to make similar
observations with the same startling
accuracy ancient china had a combination
of the two with their lunar solar
calendar featuring their own unique
menagerie of zodiac animals vedic india
used their calendar to calculate the
lifespans of various gods for example a
single day for the god brahma is equal
to 4.32 billion human years but that's
nothing on the god vishnu in the time it
takes for him to complete a single
breath a lifespan of brahma passes in
other words that's 311.04
trillion years the longest single breath
in mythological history
in time these calendars changed the way
people saw themselves you could now say
how many years you've been alive for or
in which king's reign your parent was
born
one of the earliest historians was a
greek writer called herodotus he
traveled around the known world and
wrote down all the stories he was told
real or fictional there is one event
which we know actually took place even
down to the very date and time
it was a battle between the greek
lydians and persian medes which was
interrupted by a very strange phenomenon
he writes
just as the battle was growing warm the
day was of a sudden changed into night
the medes and lydians when they observed
the change ceased fighting and were
alike anxious to have terms of peace
agreed upon what he had just described
was a solar eclipse when the moon passes
in front of the sun
since the movement of the sun moon are
predictable this battle would have
occurred on the 28th of may 585 bc
making this the first real date in
history once again the sun and moon come
together to help tell the time
for the ancient greeks history was
infused with a healthy dose of mythology
inhabiting times past are heroic
warriors capricious gods and the
ordinary people caught in between to the
greeks even time was a person the
concept was embodied in the titan
chronos the father of zeus a cruel
tyrant who had a ponchon for eating his
own children although he was later
imprisoned by zeus and the olympian gods
he lives on in time-based words like
chronology and synchronized
another culture fascinated with the
mythology of time were the maya of
central america
they were prolific astronomers and used
three different calendars each with a
specific purpose from the hub a 365-day
solar calendar for every day goings-on
the tolkien a
day calendar for ritual events and the
long count which stretches way back into
mythical history according to the long
count this era of creation started on
four aha eight kumku to you and me
that's monday august the 11th 3114
bc on this day the god tepiu and the
feathered serpent gukumats created the
land sea and sky using their thoughts
alone and made the first humans out of
maze later two heroic twins defeat the
demon lord sibalba and bring order to
the universe
contrary to popular belief the mayan
calendar does not predict the end of the
world there was mass panic that the 21st
of december was going to be doomsday of
course it wasn't this date in the mayan
calendar marked the conclusion of the
current era or baktun a unit of time
that occurs every 400 years or so
instead of a global apocalypse in 2012
the world continued as normal
much like it had when the year 1999
rolled on to the year 2000
speaking of this brings us to the
calendar we are using today our calendar
is an adapted version of the one used by
the romans it was tweaked by pope
gregory in 1582 to include leap years
hence the name the gregorian calendar
this calendar counts the years elapsed
since the birth of jesus
this practice started in the 6th century
where christian monks concluded that
jesus was probably born 754 years after
the founding of rome they refer to this
date as the first year of our lord or
one ano domino 180
religious historians are nowadays
doubtful that jesus was actually born in
that year instead they suspect he was
born in 4 bc to coincide with the reign
of king herod who features heavily in
the nativity story another religious
calendar you might not have heard of is
ano mundi in the year of our world
this counts back to the creation of
earth in the book of genesis which
allegedly took place on the 6th october
3761 bc
it's a precise date for the beginning of
the universe but i'm not sure scientists
would agree with those numbers
to this day the gregorian calendar is
used pretty much everywhere the
exception is north korea whose juche
calendar counts on the birth of its
first supreme leader kim il-sung like
the gregorian calendar north korea's
calendar starts with a miraculous birth
the story goes that the day kimmel sung
was born a bright star appeared in the
sky it was accompanied by singing
heralding the arrival of the auspicious
baby
this date is known as juche 1 the same
day coincidentally as the sinking of the
titanic as the world has become
increasingly secular many feel that
using a christian calendar is no longer
appropriate especially as two-thirds of
the world are not even christian
some have tried to introduce the
holocene calendar a universal calendar
marking the rise of modern humans they
fixed the state to the end of the last
ice age around 10 000 bc
so they simply add 10 000 onto our
current year it's a nice idea but a bit
of a mouthful and i guess all you're
doing is adding 10 000 onto a religious
calendar whilst our way of counting
years is a relic of medieval
christianity it's a convention we all
use and can agree on it helps our global
society stay organized and isn't that
the point of a calendar in the first
place
there is so much more to be said about
time from the history of clockmaking to
the astronomers who pioneered greenwich
meantime to later minds like einstein
who proposed his theory of special
relativity getting us closer to figuring
out what time actually is
these developments would not have been
possible without the work of ancient
astronomers who harnessed the power of
the sun moon and stars and created the
first systems of time keeping as well as
these calendars being achievements in
mathematics and astronomy they are also
full of stories and rich in mythology
these myths live on in today's time
keeping our years are based on the
biblical nativity story our months come
from imperial rome with july and august
named after julius caesar and augustus
and our weekdays are named after the
norse gods thursday is a day of thor
friday is the day of freyja
to this day the invention of time
remains one of humanity's longest
lasting achievements these marvelous
creations rich in mythology give us a
sense of not only when we are
but who we are as well
hey thanks for watching i've always been
fascinated with time and to the
mythology that comes with it
not only the past but also the future
you might like an earlier video of mine
past predictions of the future where i
explore what the word futuristic has
meant to different generations if you
like this video and want to see more why
not subscribe a like and a comment also
go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye
[Music]